منذ الرابع عشر من ابريل الماضي وعشرات
الالاف من السودانيين بين نزوح داخل
البلاد او اللجوء لدول الجوار بحسب بيانات
امميه حيث انه المفوضيه العليا لشؤون
اللاجئين كشفت عن ان اكثر من 700 الف شخص
فرو من ديارهم في السودان بسبب القتال بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع واضافت المنظمه
الدوليه ان عدد النازحين داخل السودان بلغ
نحو
340 الفا بحسب البيانات بينما كان ما لا
يقل عن 150 الف شخص عبروا بالفعل الحدود
السودانيه الى دول الجوار هذه الارقام
تزيد العبء على السودان الذي كان لديه
ثلاثه ملايين و700,000 نازح اصلا قبل
اندلاع القتال الحالي وايضا اكثر من مليون
لاجئ من الدول المجاوره اليوم اعلنت
مفوضيه شؤون اللاجئين عن احصاء المذهله
لاعداد اللاجئين المتوقعه حصه الاسد ستكون
لمصر مع
350 الفا من السودان حسب التوقعات تليها
جنوب السودان
240 الف لاجئ ووصل اليها بالفعل اكثر من
35 الف لاجئ ايضا توقعت مفوضيه اللاجئين
ان يصل عشرات الالاف الى دول جوار اخرى
مثل تشاد وليبيا واثيوبيا واريتريا
وجمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى طبعا تسعى
المفوضيه العليا لشؤون اللاجئين للحصول
على
445 مليون دولار اضافيه للعمل والتعامل مع
الهجره الجماعيه المتوقعه لدول الجوار
السوداني
عدد النازحين داخليا في السودان ارتفع الى
اكثر من الضعف في الاسبوع الماضي حسب
بيانات تتبع النزوح في المنظمه الدوليه
للهجره وهناك الان اكثر من 700 الف نازح
داخليا بسبب القتال الذي بدا في الخامس
عشر من ابريل وفقا لبياناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات